[Music]
on this sunday night victory for
emmanuel macron
france's centrist president stays in
power
now macron's next hurdle and what his
far-right rival wants her supporters to
do
an easter like no other in ukraine
two months of russia's invasion and no
end in sight
another phase of the pandemic waits in
the wings it's nice to be able to travel
again and and do things with your family
the recommendations before restrictions
are relaxed
global national
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us a sense of some much needed
stability in europe tonight at least on
the leadership front emanuel macron is
set to be re-elected as the president of
france exit polls show he won almost 59
percent of the runoff vote sunday with
his opponent marine le pen getting just
over 41
the margin of victory is half that of
the 2017 election which was contested
between the same two candidates the
second term for macron spares france and
its allies from a wartime shift of power
our redmond shannon has the latest on
the french election results tonight
redmond
colleen emanuel macron has become the
first french president in 20 years to be
re-elected for a second five-year term
but right up to the end this win was far
from certain turnout was down and for
many voters it appeared to be more about
deciding who they disliked the least
merci
macron cheered by his supporters under
the eiffel tower but now facing a
reduced mandate in his second term
[Applause]
the incumbent president acknowledging
those who didn't vote and those who only
voted for him in order to block marine
le pen unlike 2017 when he was the fresh
new outsider this time macron was
weighed down by the baggage of a
difficult divisive five-year term in
office managing the covet-19 pandemic
and dealing with the gelatin or yellow
vest economic protests
le pen was defiant in defeat despite
losing a presidential election for a
third time no indication that she will
step away from politics and her
far-right national rally party
she instead asked her supporters to help
block macron's agenda by turning out for
june's legislative elections the
campaign was dominated by concerns about
the rising cost of living in france
macron's critics calling him an arrogant
president of the rich as he looks to
raise the retirement age
le pen campaigned on tighter immigration
controls and supports a ban on women
wearing muslim headscarves in public she
also wanted to roll back some
integration measures within the european
union and nato
the war in ukraine was an election issue
too with macron alleging le pen was too
close to russian president vladimir
putin her party having accepted a loan
from a russian bank in 2014
the next step in france's election year
will be the legislative elections two
months from now voters will get to
decide how much power they want to place
in the hands of macron
colleen redmond shannon in london
redmond thank you
ukraine is now marking 60 days of war
and tonight an adviser to president
vladimir zelinsky says he's met with top
u.s officials in kiev the country is
also marking orthodox easter sunday and
in a message to the world zelensky vowed
resilience abigail beeman looks at how
ukrainians are trying to celebrate
easter under the cloud of russia's
invasion
a subdued orthodox easter at churches
throughout ukraine also marking two
months since the start of the russian
invasion
we heard air raid sirens after mass says
this priest it's tragic that people who
call themselves christian do such things
they didn't even stop on the biggest
celebration in the world the
resurrection of christ elsewhere no
services at all churches like this one
which survived the second world war now
no longer a place of refuge or prayer
russian president vladimir putin marked
the holiday at a church in moscow
while ukraine's president vowed
wickedness would not destroy the country
in an easter message delivered in a one
thousand year old kiev cathedral
volodymir zolensky says the u.s
secretary of state and defense secretary
were to visit kiev sunday the first
official visit by u.s officials since
russia invaded ukraine calling for more
weapons money and sanctions it's very
important when
our partners go to ukraine to see by
their own eyes what's happened
which atrocities and war crimes russian
army and russian federation
made in ukraine this week the un
secretary general is also set to visit
turkey moscow and kiev though many are
doubtful there can be a diplomatic
solution right now i don't think that
the situation on the battlefield yet
lends itself to some sort of diplomatic
compromise solution both sides still
imagine that they can win this the
biggest battle mariupol ukraine says
civilians and soldiers are still holed
up under the giant steel plant now
facing russian bombs and while
humanitarian corridors so far have not
been successful hundreds of people uh
were gathered uh at one point to to go
out of madrupo and uh russian soldiers
just came and said no we're not allowing
this to happen sunday ukraine proposed a
special round of negotiations in the
city to discuss the fate of those
trapped while russia has repeatedly
denied killing civilians abigail beeman
global news washington
more than 5 million people have escaped
ukraine since the war began according to
the u.n more than 100 000 of them have
applied to come to canada and ottawa
says it will accept an unlimited number
the federal government has set up a
program waiving a lot of visa
prerequisites that's supposed to speed
things up but as jamie dahl reports some
ukrainians say it's still taking far too
long
[Music]
images of the aftermath of a bombing on
a mall near kiev another digital daily
update from a husband left in the war
zone to his wife now in germany he is
safe and i pray
i pray every day
and be safe alina manzouk fled kiev more
than a month ago now with her young son
tim her sister and parents
this was the last time tim saw his dad
before the family was separated by this
brutal war i wanted to work
i want to normal life
i want to my child go to school or
kindergarten
or
i really wanted normal life mandzuk and
her family have been trying to come to
canada they have host families waiting
for them in calgary but the government's
fast track program to get them here is
proving for them not to be fast at all
we wait a visa to canada a long time
wait in this situation i don't
understand
why so long i was under the impression
that the
the process for getting them over here
was going to be streamlined and a lot
less red tape we can't get answers
we're still waiting on the the last
portion of the application and we don't
know when it's going to be approved
according to the federal government 46
000 applicants have been approved and 16
000 ukrainians have already arrived it
says it's opening two new large
biometric collection sites in berlin and
warsaw later this month and are
constantly addressing what they call
their processes to meet demand
alina is hopeful canada will provide her
a chance at some normalcy she is so
desperately seeking but deep down all
she truly wants is to one day return
home my heart is broken really broken
it's very hard and because we
we want to home
we want to home much
jamie doll global news calgary
at least 100 people have been killed in
an explosion at an illegal oil refinery
in nigeria officials say a fire broke
out at the facility last night and
quickly spread to two fuel storage areas
dozens of workers were caught in the
blast police are now looking for the
owner of the depot illegal refinery is
an attractive business in nigeria
because it's seen as being relatively
easy to pull off despite the risks
the bodies of three women and seven men
have been recovered from the frigid
waters of japan off the northwest coast
where a tour boat vanished yesterday 16
other people including two children are
still missing the boat issued a distress
call saying it was starting to sink
during rough weather japan's transport
ministry is now investigating why the
boat's operator which had two accidents
last year allowed the vessel to head out
at least six people including a child
have been killed after their boat
capsized off the coast of lebanon the
small dinghy was carrying around 60
people when it collided with the naval
ship the lebanese military says the
boat's captain was trying to evade
capture
migrants from lebanon pay thousands of
dollars to smugglers to take them to
europe
the country is in the grip of its worst
economic crisis in modern history
as summer draws closer more canadians
are itching to travel especially as more
restrictions ease for re-entering the
country starting tomorrow regardless of
vaccination status children aged 5 to 11
will no longer need a negative coven 19
test so long as they're with a fully
vaccinated guardian and fully vaccinated
travelers will also no longer need to
provide a quarantine plan upon arrival
that said as marnie blunt reports
experts are still urging travelers to
take precautions
more and more people taking to the sky
as cover 19 restrictions continue to
ease it's nice to be able to travel
again and and do things with your family
after being home for two years and come
monday traveling in and out of the
country is set to get a bit easier for
some with restrictions loosening again
welcome news for erica suterman and her
family she and her husband traveled to
mexico in march while testing
requirements were still in effect for
returning to canada a reason why they
left their two children at home i think
the reason we didn't take the kids was
because i didn't want to have to worry
about them you know getting coveted and
having to test and come home and my kids
don't like taking a test so it was just
such a
you know we didn't want to take them for
that reason travel agencies also
welcoming the news and they expect to
see another uptick in canadians
traveling that pre-flight test has been
expensive and it's also been a hassle
with this round of restrictions being
eased
that's really where i notice a lot more
families excited to start to travel but
fewer barriers for travelers can also
mean fewer barriers for transmission of
the virus remember that the more that
mandates and restrictions are dropped
the more that gives us the opportunity
to be mobile to get around to be around
more people and of course that's what
the virus likes epidemiologists say
travelers should research both levels of
restrictions and levels of risk at their
vacation destination and with the u.s
dropping mass mandates for air and train
travel amid rising cases now is the time
to take extra precaution i would
strongly encourage people
to be wearing a well fitted mask and to
wear it consistently and suderman plans
on doing just that as she looks ahead to
planning a trip to mexico this time for
the entire family i would definitely
want our trip to be
coveted free so masking all the way
marty blunt global news winnipeg
despite growing anger among residents
china is ramping up its zero coveted
strategy in shanghai with millions still
in lockdown authorities are now closing
off entire neighborhoods with barriers
and fences they've also sealed off
entrances to buildings where infections
have been detected many residents
continue to criticize the city's
approach citing poor quarantine
protocols and facilities and a lack of
access to food and medical aid
coming up as rents in this country go
through the roof so too are frustrations
from groceries to gas canadians are
paying more for well just about
everything these days and you can add
rent to the list of expenses that just
keep climbing now as dan spector reports
the calls are growing louder for
governments to do more to keep them
affordable
a loud beginning to a sunday
demonstration that saw hundreds gather
in montreal to demand better access to
affordable housing we're seeing prices
go up everywhere
this type of turnout and rentals here in
quebec are relatively inexpensive when
compared to other parts of the country
according to new data from rentals.ca
the average rent in the city jumped 3.5
percent in the last year the increase in
vancouver was nearly 10 times that this
single mom left bc for the lower housing
prices in montreal i was in school at
the time we just had our daughter
and it was impossible
after a dip during the pandemic rents
across the country are rising again
vancouver rents year over year for all
property types for up almost 30 percent
toronto
a little over 14 percent
vancouver and toronto remain the most
expensive places to rent in canada but
affording an apartment is getting harder
almost everywhere
there are many people who are now priced
out of home ownership who are looking to
rent and who are you know who are
competing against the folks who probably
couldn't have afforded to buy a house in
the first place
all over the country supply is just not
keeping up with demand and with the
price of owning a home skyrocketing in
recent years inflation denting people's
wallets the rental market has become
even more competitive this government is
definitely interested in seeing more
housing supply affordable housing was
one of the cornerstones of this month's
federal budget the government promising
10 billion dollars to tackle the crisis
no matter how cheap
you know rents are on on the private
market they're never going to be cheap
enough for a very large sector of the
population experts say rezoning for high
density development and building more
subsidized housing are among the
solutions even still demand will likely
continue to outpace supply as
immigration rises and more units are
turned back into short-term rentals with
international tourism making its return
government can make things less worse
but i think better is going to be pretty
challenging
that means protests like this one are
likely to continue popping up across the
country and spectre global news montreal
[Applause]
and they're off after a two-year hiatus
due to the pandemic the vancouver sun
run finally kicked off in person today
thousands of racers packed the city
streets for one of the largest road
races in north america but some didn't
wait for today's starting pistol they
got their 10k run in over the last week
as participants were still allowed to
participate on their own
another boost for bc's reputation as
host to major international sporting
events following the 2010 olympics it's
now considering a 2030 games bid
vancouver is also on the short list for
world cup soccer matches in 2026 and
last week a royal announced the invictus
games are coming to vancouver and
whistler in 2025. paul johnson has the
details
i'm thrilled to announce that the
invictus games foundation
has selected
canada
to host the first ever winter hybrid
games in 2024. it will be the first
invictus games in vancouver and whistler
the first to feature winter sports and
the first major international sporting
event in partnership with the musqueam
squamish and celelutooth people
established by prince harry in 2014 the
invictus games will see 500 athletes
from 20 countries all of them wounded
injured or sick former military men and
women who were using sport as part of
their recovery
vancouver's pierce barrassa is a retired
canadian forces corporal who was wounded
in afghanistan he's a previous invictus
athlete and intends to be involved in
some way in the 2025 games either as a
competitor volunteer or spectator i
think it really changed my life you know
i
i was at the time where i had just
released from the military and i was a
little bit uh lost but uh
i got accepted to be part of the victus
games and got back into sport and it
really uh
really put me on a
positive path forward
toward my recovery and
in my career in this winter version the
invictus games will have new events like
alpine and nordic skiing and wheelchair
curling
vancouver and whistler are well
positioned to stage it there won't be
building any new facilities we've got
everything in place of course from
the 2010 games
in its short history the invictus
movement has been a success right from
the start
and as they branch out into competition
on snow and ice its founder has every
reason to expect that success to
continue don't worry
we'll still have many of the core sports
the invictus games that you know and
love they'll just be a little cooler
paul johnson global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's york canada is the sunset in
kolluk tuk
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen will
be back at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a good night
[Music]
you